uh can we bring in charles is he there
hey hey chuck how are you
what's up brother is the series over
yes sir it's over it's a wrap uh
you know what listen miami just under
man
you know when jimmy butler went crazy
the other night that extended it one
game
i mean he was amazing in game three but
listen they're under man
and uh it's over if you could have
picked a team to face
the lakers any team in the finals who
would you pick
to make it a more interesting matchup
well that was two teams that would have
been interested to match up uh
the clippers and the milwaukee bucks it
you know dan it's about matchups
you know listen miami uh supposed to out
coach
boston and milwaukee that was all about
coaching
uh but the clippers and the milwaukee
bucks would have been
much much tougher match-ups when you
hear
teams that have chemistry problems like
the clippers suddenly had chemistry
problems
did they have chemistry problems before
they got to the bubble or was it just in
the bubble that they had chemistry
issues
well you know i hate when i hear that
because when they won the first round
and they were up 3-1 nobody talked about
chemistry
i mean think about that man they won a
playoff series
and they were 3-1 double digits in games
five and six
nobody talked about chemistry they just
didn't play good
you know uh paul george was awful lou
williams was awful montres harrell was
awful
so they just did not play well so uh no
it had nothing to do with chemistry
that's just bogus
who's your mvp for the nba finals
wow well i think lebron is going to win
it but a.d
has been amazing even last night
watching the game
his defensive like he made a plays in
the first half that people are not going
to talk about
the play on tyler hero where he missed
the layup and then he blocked kelly
olynyk
um he blocked him on that play so
listen lebron is probably going to win
it but listen let's be realistic the
reason they're going to win the finals
is because of a.d
but then we said that six months ago we
said if a.d
plays like he's capable the lakers are
going to win the championship and i'm
never going to say anything bad about
lebron this
i got respect and admiration for him
he's amazing
player and he's even probably even a
better man
but uh they're going to win because of
a.d
is lebron picking his spots i i it
just feels like this is the first time
i've ever seen him pace himself
a little more am i reading into too much
here or are you seeing this that maybe
lebron is
you know at times mortal in the nba uh
you know no i i don't know in order to
write word but listen when you have
ethnic athletes
listen they have uh jimmy
iguodala j crowder who are terrific
defenders
but a.d has an advantage every single
night
he reminds me of dirk nowitzki
kevin durant uh you know those guys
who do you put on a.d you can't put a
big guy on him you can't put a little
guy on him
that's the same way i felt about dirk
nowitzki and uh kevin durant who do you
put on kevin durant you put a little guy
on him
he's too big you put a big gal and he's
there too slow
and that's what you get when you get
anthony davis like i don't know who you
can put on anthony davis there's nobody
you can put on him when he doesn't have
an advantage
so lebron has deferred to him quite a
bit rightfully so
and that's why they're going to win the
championship
and you don't have home court you know
when people say well is this really a
championship and an asterisk i think
it's been tougher
to win a championship this year than it
would be if this was just a regular
season
you know i don't know about that but i
will say
i thought that could be an asterisk that
we had like if the
if uh if if all the great players got to
covet
and we had the sacramento kings against
the new york knicks for the championship
i thought that i thought i'll give you
an asterisk then i'll give you an
asterisk there
but you know what listen you know i'm so
glad you asked me that question dan
because man i got to take my hat off to
adam silver
and uh first and foremost but also the
medical staff
and the players listen i was very
cynical when this thing first started
i'm like there's no way they can go
three months yeah there's no way they
can go three months and not have an
outbreak
they did it damn same thing hey shout
out to my boy john cooper
uh head coach of the tampa bay lightning
uh he's been my boy for a long time they
won the stanley cup
i thought it was no way possible for
these teams to go
three months basically without the
covert so
gary batman and hockey and adam silver
but i can say i get a players a lot of
credit too because for us to go
then for us to go i saw one night we had
a guy on the show last night he been 100
days in the bubble
to go three months without any positive
test is
one of the most amazing things that i've
ever seen
could you have pulled that off if you
were a player
i mean i think it depends on how good
yeah i mean i think
all the players had to but i think it
depends on how good your team is like
the good team
you notice anything that really happened
uh the only people were complaining were
guys on bad teams who were gonna be away
for a couple months
but man these players and adam silver
the doctors
uh all the people working at the hotels
down there
uh same thing a shout out to the seattle
storm or the wnba
i mean to go three months with i mean
think about it
the president of the united states has
coveted
and like he's probably you know like
he's probably in the safest place he's
not a
but for these players and women in the
wnba and
nhl to go three months without an
outbreak it's one of the most amazing
things ever
plain and simple did you ever have a
false positive
no i was negative okay yeah yeah i was
negative
but you know hey man i want to give my
thoughts and
thoughts out there to everybody who had
the disease
uh hey listen and also i want to uh
bless them if you lost somebody bless
you but man
i just want to think about all the
people out there who lost their jobs
doing this pandemic
then you know this has been like the
craziest thing in our lifetime
and there's so many people who lost
their job and never gonna get it back
so i feel bad for those people because
like we had a crazy time right now
i mean and we don't even know i mean
i've been talking to tnt we don't even
know when nba gonna start again it's
crazy right now our world we're living
in
yeah we're probably looking at uh the
end of january or february uh but you
know training camp would be starting now
in a normal year we're talking to
charles barkley the hall of famer uh doc
rivers to
philly what do you think
well it's going to pin on joelle and ben
those guys got to get this
the crap together uh i like both of them
as people but it's time for them to grow
up and reach
all uh listen right now they're all
stars it's time for them to be
superstars
you know uh ben's listen we got to make
sure joelle's got to get in shape
you know dan we give you 167 million
dollars we should be worried about your
conditioning
would you trade one of those two
i would not right now uh but
we still shouldn't be wondering if a guy
can shoot or a guy's going to get in
shape if i just gave him 170 million
dollars the last
two years uh it's time for them to grow
up
and be better than all stars they got so
much talent
and they're really nice kids both but
it's time for them to grow up
they just got their coach fired now they
got another coach
you know and listen if i was those two
guys you know then i got one coach fired
and i was embarrassed i mean we had a
bad team but as a great player i was
embarrassed
because i was like man i just got a guy
fired
i got the assistance fired i i was
embarrassed and i hope those two guys
like you know man i just gotta got fired
that's embarrassing and i hope they grow
up and it's time for them they're in the
prime of their career
it's time to grow up and be dominant
does another title change where lebron
is
all time well it moved in closer to kobe
um listen i'm never gonna say anything
bad about lebron i think
one another try to move him closer to
kobe
uh uh but he he's amazing
nothing but respect but i think it you
know i got him six on my left
uh excuse me seventh right behind kobe
so i think if he wins
i think he wins two more i would move
him ahead of kobe
to be honest with you but just move him
a lot closer to kobe in in my there's
just on my list and my personal opinion
so not even in the top five all the time
he's seven
dan yeah i know i just i wanted to i
wanted to ask the question because
i was surprised that he's not even in
your top five
all the time i got him number seven
behind kobe bryant when he wins
when he wins this year you know it'll
move a lot closer i mean dan he is
playing with anthony davis
um yeah most great players played with
great players
yes you are correct but the difference
is i i've always believed that lebron
manufactured
when he went to miami and got to wayne
and chris
and then when he went to the lakers he
you know once anthony davis signed with
clutch sports you knew it was just a
matter of time before he came to the
lakers
so listen like i said i'm never gonna
say anything bad about lebron
but you do have to factor in he does
manufacture his teams where they become
really good
quickly yeah but we've seen that with
great players
like who like who that have manufactured
their teams
like who well kevin durant did
that's why he wouldn't eat that on my
list but steph curry got credit for a
title
and kevin durant came there so nobody
said boy you can't give steph that one
title
was step one one before before kd came
that's true but that doesn't mean we're
not going to take away that title
and that's a manufactured that's a
manufactured lineup but
but but i'm not going to move him up on
the list because
those two with kd are manufactured
let me tell you something as much as i
like kd
i haven't moved him up because his was
manufactured also
but you look at the boston celtics with
bill russell
none of those guys left the team like
nobody had free agency you couldn't
leave so you had a lineup of what do
they have
eight hall of famers and a hall of fame
coach
and bill russell you're not factoring
that in these guys couldn't leave
yeah but but none of those other guys on
my list only beer russell's on my list
yeah but these are all hall of famers
bill russell played with eight or seven
hall of famers in that lineup
yeah i know and i'm saying but i don't
count those other guys they're bus
riders man they're not bus drivers the
only person on that team
the only person on that team that i'm
putting on my list is bill russell
those other guys are they're they're bus
riders they're not bus drivers
listen when i'm talking about my rush my
mount rushmore
and lebron's on that you have to be a
bus driver you can't be a bus rider
kevin durant is still a bus rider until
he wins one in brooklyn and let me tell
you something
i i have no idea what the hell going on
i was gonna bring that up to you when
kyrie
says we don't really have a head coach
some nights it'll be me
sometimes it'll be k.d and sometimes
it'll be steve nash
boy what can we go wrong hey dan first
of all
he did not say steve nash he said
sometimes it'll be me
hey he went to the assistant assistant
you know that was one of the craziest
things i've ever heard
an nba player say i have no idea
i mean that was flat out crazy yeah
and and you know what i think it's going
to be fascinating watching those guys
especially in new york and
i i don't think it's gonna be a good
fascinating or a bad fascinating though
i think it's gonna be a bad fascination
yeah i don't think either one of those
guys
they're lucky they don't play for the
next but i think because they're so high
profile
and all the stuff that kyrie has said
the last couple years
i think they're gonna get to see the
same media attention
that the knicks get and i think it's
going to be fascinating
and i and i can't wait to watch
how you doing on nfl games
you know it's been very difficult to bet
to be honest with you dan because
they've taken away the home field
i tell people home field first of all
home
home court home field always means
something in sports
but i think it means a lot more in
college football
and pro football so i i have had a tough
time
trying to figure out especially with no
preseason games so i think we're still
in the preseason
but i'm having a difficult time betting
on games
because there's no home field advantage
anymore i got one for you
yeah army versus the citadel
take army first half cover are you crazy
yes listen i'm not betting on army
against citadel please stop
wait do you want to make money or like
why do you bet
i bet to make money okay and you haven't
made money
well well because well actually i am uh
i didn't vet
i did not bet the first two weeks
because i wanted to see some games
right now i think i'm six
and two for the season i did not bet
until the week three so i'm six and two
so i'm up four games
yeah but every super bowl i always say
just give me your money
and then i'll hold on to it and then you
won't lose it
well what was the super bowl last year
kansas city chiefs i won last year
the only time i've lost in the last
three or four years was those atlanta
[Laughter]
the atlanta falcons what they've done in
the super bowl
yeah and what they did against the
cowboys are two of the biggest choke
jobs in the history of civilization what
would you have won if the falcons won
the super bowl
a hundred thousand dollars i bet a
hundred thousand dollars on them
and they listen let me tell you
something i was drunk
at halftime i was doing shots
hey i was up 28 to three i was feeling
it
and then one of my friends roy green
says
yo man the game's done over here i said
dude we're up 28
and then he says no man the falcons are
playing not to lose
they're trying to walk the ball up and
down the court just let the shot clock
go down
um and he was 100 correct and as soon as
brady got the ball for the last time
you knew it was over i know you knew it
was over
damn and and and when they when they had
the ball
and on the first play they got sacked
and new england called the timer all
they do is run the ball three times
make them gonna use up their three
timeout the kicker field goal the game
is over
i mean uh dan that that was so
heartbreaking that was heartbreaking
well at least you did you sober up in
the second half
well no i just got drunk
[Laughter]
that's one thing about about gambling
you drink when you're gonna win but you
drink
uh good to talk to you glad you're safe
tell the boys tnt we said hello and uh
thanks for joining us
all right man hey keep up the great work
i am officially on vacation now
so i'm heading to the desert to play
golf for the next uh
uh whenever they start again come on out
and visit me do the show for my house i
told you
we we want to we'd have to have some
some safety protocols to get to the
compound but
you know we'd love to do that all right
i mean
thank you buddy that's uh charles
barkley a hall of famer